LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
ZOE KRAVITZ!
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
♪
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
IT IS SO FANTASTIC TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M YOUR HOST, ZOE KRAVITZ.
IT IS SO FANTASTIC TO BE HERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I'M YOUR HOST, ZOE KRAVITZ.
I CURRENTLY HAVE A NEW MOVIE OUT
[ APPLAUSE ]
CALLED "THE BATMAN."
IN THE MOVIE, I PLAY CATWOMAN.
SORRY, THE CATWOMAN.
TO PREPARE FOR THE ROLE, I
WATCHED THE MOVIE MUSICAL "CATS"
EVERY DAY FOR A YEAR.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY HOW I HEARD
JOAQUIN PHOENIX PREPARED TO PLAY
THE JOKER.
>> SOMEONE HERE TALKING ABOUT
"CATS?"
>> I WAS, YEAH.
I WAS JUST DOING THE MONOLOGUE.
YOU'RE ALSO CATWOMAN?
>> YES.
I'M CATWOMAN FROM THE '90S.
THE ONE WITH THE WHIP.
YOU KNOW.
LIKE CATS HAVE.
SO YOU'RE PART OF A PROUD
LINEAGE OF CATWOMEN, EACH WITH
OUR OWN ORIGIN STORIES.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW MINE?
>> YEAH, SURE, WHAT'S YOURS?
>> I FELL OUT OF A WINDOW INTO A
PILE OF CATS.
THEY LICKED ME BACK TO LIFE, AND
NOW IT'S JUST LIKE SANDY FROM A
PORNO VERSION OF "GREASE."
IT'S STILL CALLED "GREASE."
>> COOL.
WELL -- THANK YOU, IT'S REALLY
GREAT TO HAVE A FELLOW CATWOMAN
SUPPORT.
I SHOULD PROBABLY GET BACK TO --
>> HANG ON, WE MUST FIRE UP THE
CAT SIGNAL.
>> I'M SORRY, CAT SIGNAL?
>> YEAH, FOR ANY TIME YOU NEED A
CATWOMAN.
BEHOLD.
>> OH, MY GOD!
I LOVE THAT.
IT'S A NOBLE CAT READY TO POUNCE
OFF THE LEDGE.
>> OR MAYBE IT'S JUST DOING ITS
BIZ IN THE LITTER BOX.
>> I SAW THE SIGNAL, IS SOMEONE
IN DANGER?
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU'RE CATWOMAN TOO?
>> INDUBITABLY.
I WAS THE FIRST BLACK CATWOMAN.
>> RIGHT, YES, OF COURSE,
EARTHA KITT FROM THE 1960S TV
VERSION.
>> YEAH, PEOPLE CALLED IT CAMPY,
TURNS OUT IT WAS SUPER GAY.
BE GRATEFUL YOUR OUTFIT ISN'T
LATEX BECAUSE THIS IS HOW I
SNEAK UP ON BAD GUYS.
>> WOW.
YOU KNOW, IT ACTUALLY DOES FEEL
NICE HAVING ALL THIS CATWOMAN
ENERGY UP HERE, BUT I REALLY
SHOULD GET BACK TO THE
MONOLOGUE.
SO CAN WE TURN OFF THE CAT
SIGNAL BEFORE WE --
>> BEFORE ME?
>> ANOTHER CATWOMAN?
>> YEAH.
YEAH, I'M MORE OF A CAT LADY, I
GUESS.
THIS IS MY HUSBAND.
SORRY CAT, AND WE'RE HERE TO
MEET ROSALIA.
DO YOU TAKE ME TO HER OR HOW
DOES THAT WORK?
>> I DON'T THINK I CAN DO THAT
RIGHT NOW, I KIND OF HAVE TO
HOST THE SHOW, SO --
>> OH, YEAH.
I GET IT.
YOU KNOW, I HOSTED THE SHOW
DOZENS OF TIMES.
IN MY MIND.
WHERE IT'S CALLED "SATURDAY
NIGHT CATS."
>> NOT "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"?
>> DANG IT.
>> OKAY, WOW.
I REALLY WAS NOT EXPECTING TO
MEET SO MANY CAT -- PEOPLE.
AND NOT THAT I'M NOT LOVING IT,
BUT MAYBE THAT'S ENOUGH, SO
LET'S JUST --
>> EVEN IF THE NEXT ONE WAS DOJA
CAT?
>> OH, MY GOD, IS SHE HERE?
>> NO, BUT THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
ME.
IT IS I, KAT WILLIAMS!
>> COME ON.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN A WOMAN.
>> I AM A LOVER OF WOMEN, MEOW!
AND IF I WANTED TO MEET ROSALIA,
HOW WOULD I DO THAT?
>> SERIOUSLY, IS THERE AN OFF
BUTTON SOMEWHERE?
>> THE CAT SIGNAL BROUGHT US ALL
TOGETHER.
>> AND RIGHT NOW, THE WORLD
NEEDS AS MANY CAT WOMEN AS IT
CAN GET.
NOW LET'S GO FIGHT SOME CRIME,
YES!
>> OKAY.
LOOKS LIKE THAT'S DONE.
SO I CAN FINALLY SAY WHAT I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO SAY.
WHICH IS, WE'VE GOT A GREAT SHOW
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
ROSALIA IS HERE.
STICK AROUND, AND WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK!